Please welcome the one and only,
the funny, the brilliant Craig Robinson.
(audience cheering)
Hi!
Hello, how are you?
I'm so happy that you're here.
And I'm so glad to be here, thank you for having me.
Please have a sit.
Hey, hey, hey!
Hello!
Craig, when did you burst onto the scene?
Because I could swear it was easily 40 something years ago.
Like I don't remember life without you.
But sometimes when I look at your resume and I'm like,
"Oh," like you didn't start 40 something years ago.
I got to Hollywood in 1999.
And then, I think "The Office" was about 2004.
Well, that is a long time ago now if you think about it.
But you did stand-up.
I do stand-up still.
I mean, yeah exactly.
Yeah, yeah.
(audience clapping)
And is it true that there's something
like of a story of stand-up X a rubber chicken?
Oh yeah.
Oh, when I was getting started,
there was this place in Chicago
they had a night called Heckler's Heaven.
And you got three minutes, okay, of nobody bothering you.
And then, you had eight minutes total
if you didn't get a rubber chicken.
Three people in the audience had a rubber chicken.
So once that three-minute bell hit,
if somebody wants to throw the rubber chicken at you,
you had to get off stage.
And I got two rubber chickens,
I said, "I'm not getting a third," so I got off.
And then, the next week I came back with my keyboard
and that's all she wrote,
and now do stand-up with the keyboard.
(audience clapping)
I guess it like sharpens your skills.
Well, it certainly keeps you on your toes,
yeah, to get to the jokes.
Is it true that you have written yourself notes
about kind of where you wanna go in life,
and if so, why do you do that?
I love this.
When I was in college
that's when I felt like comedy chose me.
And I wrote a note to myself 'cause I knew
I was getting into comedy.
And I said, "You are going to be a great comedian,"
and I crossed out, "going to be."
I said, "You are a great comedian."
I really think that words matter.
Absolutely.
And a turn of phrase, a choice of words,
pulling out going to be rather than I am.
Those things I think are like inextricably linked
with belief.
Yeah, in sinks in for sure.
(upbeat music)